hi there steve coffin here again
today i want to talk about a subject
that um
often comes up
and people often challenge me on it
and that is this issue of learning the
basics learning the fundamentals
how do we learn the fundamentals of a
language
my answer is we don't
at least i'm not able to do so there are
people there's tim ferriss who's got his
how to learn any language in in an hour
where he deconstructs the language and
there are other people who i just
finished watching a video uh by someone
talking uh this was a russian person who
lives in sweden talking about learning
languages on your own and he says that
we should begin by reading a little book
on linguistics or even learning
esperanto to get a sense of the
terminology grammatical terminology
that's used so that we can master the
grammar from the beginning
i
can't do that it may be that i am sure
there are people who can do that who are
linguistics experts who can read the
rules and immediately understand how the
language functions i can't because i
have found that the rules vary so much
from language to language and very often
the way things are said some of the
basic structures in a language new
language which russian was for me or
czech or you know japanese they're so
different from my own that the
explanations
of how they work don't make much
sense to me they don't make sense until
i have had a lot of exposure to the
language so
again you know
and i my own advice to people is not to
worry about it i learned japanese and
chinese without being aware of a single
grammatical term
uh with russian i i did get more
involved because russian is is more
complicated in terms of grammar
so that i know that there are these
aspects of verbs but i i still don't
fully understand the difference and i've
read the explanations many many times
uh and there are lots of these uh rules
uh and lots of these different
structures and i just find that that uh
i prefer to go on my merry way
acquiring words
learning
understanding more and bit by bit some
of these rules become clearer so i don't
believe you can nail down the
fundamentals not at all
unless you are particularly gifted or
have a special predilection for
for grammar it's not something that
works for me i don't think it works for
the majority of people because the
majority of people that i've spoken to
complain about being turned off
their grammar studies or turned off
their language studies in school because
of the emphasis on grammar so that
doesn't mean that i don't think you
should learn to speak properly
but i think you learn to speak properly
by paying attention
to the patterns of the language and i
think that's something that we can do
looking at examples and right from the
beginning making an effort to notice
what is happening in the language notice
how it is different from
our own language and that's fun to do
and if we struggle to identify these
patterns on our own and struggle to
understand texts and there's always
patterns that don't make sense to us
i think then when we eventually are
familiar enough with that pattern that
we can actually read an explanation of
that pattern and make sense of it that
we learn it better and again there was
an article in uh on time magazine about
how if we bumble along and struggle on
our own we learn better than if we are
given a uh uh you know ready-made
formula explanation from the teacher
it's it's much better to have
experienced something on your own then
maybe get a little help afterwards
to point you in the right direction but
at least then you have some experience
what is the nature of the problem so uh
i very much believe that and i've said
this before but it comes up time and
time again that to nailing the
fundamentals and this came up i was
recently on a on a thread at this how to
learn any language forum and this was
again one of the comments you know you
have to begin by learning the
fundamentals and i just i just find this
completely alien to how i have learned
languages so
all the more power to the people who do
it that way but i think there are a lot
of people who cannot deal with these
rules upfront
and to those people i would suggest just
discover the language learn a few words
don't worry if it's a bit fuzzy
struggling with that fuzziness is
actually helping you uh you do have to
go back and and occasionally look at the
explanations but every time you look at
the explanations if you find that you
don't fully understand them or you can't
remember the rules or the endings don't
worry about it it's all part of that
bumbling process that struggling process
that's going to help you learn
another thing that was in again in that
video by the professor from madalena
university in sweden
was the idea that every time we see a
word or learn a word we should repeat it
we should try to use it
again i think this is
just not practical
because
we want to have as large as possible
a passive vocabulary so that we can read
so that we can understand native
speakers who always have a much larger
vocabulary than we have so that the
words that we need to use
is actually quite a small subset of the
words that we need to understand
so that the idea that you would limit
yourself only to vocabulary that you are
able to use to me is impractical
i am motivated to read novels now not
everybody wants to read novels or read
about history but i am motivated to have
intelligent conversations with people
and those people in the foreign language
will all have a much larger vocabulary
than i have i need to understand them
first and foremost and i need to have a
subset
that i can use now there are ways we do
eventually have to work on
uh you know the active vocabulary and i
do that uh you know by reviewing
vocabulary reading
you know as i've said before in grammar
books the answers rather than the
questions or reading you know the
examples that we create at link in every
link we've got five ten examples
depending on or sometimes fewer and
reading them reading them out loud now
i'm spending some time doing that on
those words that i think are important
to me and those structures that are
important to me but i can only spend a
limited amount of time on that because
i'm still motivated to expand my
vocabulary so that i can understand more
so that i can pick up a book and enjoy
it so
all i'm saying is that it's a long
process
and the idea that you can somehow nail
down the fundamentals at the beginning
i don't believe it i think you can have
a general overview
uh and typically and i always recommend
that people get themselves a little
starter book in a language and that's
really all you need you know it could be
teach yourself it could be as email it
to me it doesn't matter whether it's
colloquial or whatever it is
if you read through that you'll get some
sense of some of the issues in the
language you won't a lot of the stuff
just flies by you you read it
yeah but you don't really quite know
what they mean
you i mean this thing is well worn
because i have to go back time and time
again
and as i have had more experience with
the language these things start to make
more
and more sense to me so the fundamentals
don't worry about the fundamentals learn
about enjoying the language and a big
thing
is the big decision we have to make is
where to spend the time if you have
eight hours a day then you have one
range of decisions to make and you have
to have a variety of activities in order
to keep you
um you know on task otherwise the brain
goes numb after a while but if you only
have a limited amount of time
then you know you have to fit it in so
listening obviously fits in very nicely
reading if you have the time to watch a
movie fine but there's always that
decision should i work on expanding my
passive vocabulary or should i work on
trying to activate more of that
vocabulary this also depends on your
needs
you know now that i'm going to prague as
i get closer and closer to that date i
will be working harder to try to prepare
some of that vocabulary make sure that i
i'm close to being able to activate it
and when the need arises when i'm in
prague i'm confident that a lot of those
words are just going to start coming out
i know that i should write more writing
is very good
but again i don't have the time and
perhaps the motivation to do so so these
are always choices that uh that we have
to make but i think you know where i
have
kind of you know disagree with a number
of these other people who are you know
focusing on activating the vocabulary up
front um learning the fundamentals up
front i find it very difficult to do
and i think there's nothing wrong for
those of us who don't enjoy doing that
for those that do go for it those of us
who are like me who don't enjoy the
language enjoy it passively enjoy
listening enjoy reading enjoy
discovering more and more of it
and when you have the need and the
opportunity to use it you'll find that a
lot of it will come
come
out you know you will start to be
activated and
yeah you'll make some mistakes and if as
you confront your mistakes in your
conversations and so forth and so on
that'll also help you notice when you're
again you're listening and reading so
learning the fundamentals up front
uh i don't think it's possible to do
that's my take on it and uh
again look forward to your views
people often say that i'm sort of i
think that everybody learns the same way
and i shouldn't be pontificating well
you know other people can say how they
like to learn languages and i'm going to
say how i like to learn languages and i
know from talking to many people that a
lot of learners do not like to be forced
to speak right up front a lot of
learners have a lot of trouble dealing
with grammar up front because it's it's
just it's very difficult to get a hold
of without a lot of experience so that's
however many uh you know of the learners
that are out there and to them i offer
my advice
uh they can take it or leave it and
there is no shortage of people on the
internet offering advice on language
learning and people can choose
and experiment and see what works best
for them thanks for listening